what are some of the most unique random
strange side hustles you've seen unique
random i mean so i've been doing this
podcast uh every single day since uh
january 1 2017. it's a daily podcast
comes out seven days a week so we're on
episode 1700 something you know and i'm
telling all these different different
stories so um
yeah like let's see like i had somebody
who is doing dating app coaching like
for your dating profile
for men right so this is a woman who's
helping men have a better you know
dating profile she was making a lot of
money with that okay there was um
there's this couple that uh was really
into dachshunds like the dog you know
but specifically dachshunds like not all
dogs just toxins so they created this
website uh that's like e-commerce for
boxing lovers if it if it's not a
million dollar you know a year business
right now it is high six figures like
and it's all
you know right but specificity is the
thing specificity um
there's so much to that i mean so i've
had manufacturing stuff i've had like
lots of service stuff give me i actually
i actually i want to be able to get our
audience let's try to get out of your
brain see if we can extract 10 of them
so far i have three we got to get seven
more okay so one okay we have dating app
coaching which by the way i think so
many people would actually want to help
with that right because it i guess it
would be the sales pitch will be what
i'm going to help you increase the
chance of getting the girl that you want
by making adjustments on your profile
fantastic so the couple dachshund dogs
that's going to make a very niche which
what you talked about number three is
the uh the fortnight when you talk about
the kids seven thousand dollars a month
consulting how to play that game what
else keep going tell us yeah yeah let's
see let's see um there's a woman who um
she's in florida actually she created
this uh product called a rinsaroo which
is like a shower
like a shower handle attachment to like
you know rinse off your shoes if you're
on the beach or rinse off a dog she's
going to the beach with her big family
and like there is just one shower in the
house she created this this is also
multiple six figure now very low startup
costs
um
let's see what else do we got
i did this guy this guy was um
uh was doing drop ship so drop shipping
you know for anybody doesn't know it's
like you're you're buying something and
the company is sending that out you know
to other people so you don't actually
have to touch the inventory so he was
selling live crickets
to reptile owners
so he's like actually selling insects
but he doesn't have to touch that right
he's not doing the inventory
you know and so he's making like a few
thousand dollars it's not like a million
dollar business yeah still
right
um let's see what else we got um i did a
guy who wrote a blog about fish tanks so
not fish just fish tanks again the
specificity like going to buy an
aquarium you want to buy a fish tank so
he monetizes this using affiliate
marketing right so people are googling
all the time you know which aquarium
should i buy and they're googling the
names of specific models this is a very
uncompetitive niche right like it's not
like everybody's like i'm going to get
into the fish tank market so he's able
to like rank really high in seo people
come and read his articles they click
the links and you know so he actually
set this up this is a guy from the uk
he set it up as a random project like
one weekend you know what's his name do
you know the company's name is is it
something that we can give him i can
find it real quick um
but um it was actually one of the second
stories i ever had on the on the podcast
um
so i'll get it for you but um he set
this up in a very short period of time
we just googled blogging for fish tanks
you're probably gonna find that story um
and
you know set it up in a short period of
time never get anything else with it and
like years and years goes goes by and
he's still making like three to five
hundred dollars a month from it so three
to five hundred dollars a month for
something you don't do anything for
great yeah no question about it yep
right what else so we got four more to
go we're gonna we're gonna put that
brain of yours to work and we're gonna
come up with a four more give me four
more
it's a good challenge did i did a
sneaker reseller story recently so maybe
he's like following in your footsteps
literally
um with that that dude was doing really
well um he had figured out they have all
these apps now when like a new model
dropped since he had written some
algorithm and then built up this
customer relationship base
um
i had like a librarian who was a dj and
she kind of created this like library dj
kind of model that she's doing in
different cities so she's like traveling
for it
uh what's what's her name so she dressed
like a librarian like
i don't know everybody's name
no no no no not name no but what is her
niche what is it like by the way i found
the one story british man earned 700 a
month writing fish tank reviews we'll
put the link below if people want to see
that but the librarian dj what's her
niche does she dress like a librarian
does she have a she actually is a
librarian you know she is a librarian
she's a little bit older um so she's not
like what you would expect to be i think
that's part of it it's like this you
know kind of surprise but there's a
whole like like literacy tie into it
andrea graham andrea graham is that her
name andrea graham librarian most
recently i've done
a lot of stories i did a textbook
reseller this is actually something this
is something people can do right now
like a guy at college you know is like
buying all these textbooks and like
finding a way to like create
this model where he's matching students
with textbooks and that basically pays
his way through grad school so what does
he do say unpack that again textbook he
uh
yep
uh he's basically bought it's a very
simple model he's buying and reselling
textbooks you know and he does it both
locally and online okay uh speaking of
paying your way through college there
was a woman who
she she bred rabbits so she was like a
rabbit breeder and actually made enough
money from that to pay for for college
um also very low startup cost there
you know so all these kind of things
like it's not like everybody should go
it's not like i'm saying you know you
need to go out and like
drop shift live crickets you need to
become a librarian dj it's really
important to say like
there's something you can do like
whatever your thing is no matter how
yeah you think like nobody else is
interested in this thing but you have
something that you're interested in you
know and and there and there is there
here's here's i think i'm probably at
nine nine or ten now um there's a woman
uh who
did some videos like an online course
about baking bread not just bread but
sourdough bread again the niche
sourdough bread her name is teresa i
forget her last name
but she made these videos for
you to me i think and they totally blew
up and she got like a hundred thousand
dollars to make these videos about
sourdough bread and then she made the
sequel and then another video like all
the courses are about sourdough bread
so the first one was filmed with her
iphone and her kitchen and bad lighting
and no audio qual like all that kind of
stuff because
you know it doesn't matter it's like the
knowledge it's the knowledge and then
she gets better and improves things
along the way so if she can make all
this money with sourdough bread i know
there's something for everybody so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you